whoever walked through the door to
number ten this week will be walking
straight into a diplomatic storm the
hijacking of a UK flag tanker was
according to the defense secretary a
hostile acts committed by the Iranian
regime but Iran has hit back demanding
the UK stops being an accessory to what
it depart describes as the economic
terrorism of the US well joining us now
is the defense minister tobias l-word
thank you very much for being on the
program today so how will the UK respond
to what we're seeing in a war well
firstly we need to try and deescalate
this this we've seen a ratcheting up of
tensions in the Middle East not least
with what's happened with the montrose
engagement only a week ago we've seen
the Norwegian and Japanese tankers
already hit a couple weeks ago as well
and as you imply this is actually
forming part of a wider geopolitical
challenge that Iran is facing with the
West so our first and most important
responsibility is to make sure that we
get a solution to the issue to do with
the current ship make sure other British
flagged the ships are safe to operate in
this this waters and then look at there
this wider picture of actually having a
working proper professional register
with Iran but this is a hostile act
let's not dodge away from that this is a
serious matter for which Iran must must
recognize when you talk about
de-escalating tensions
does that mean sanctions and things like
that are off the table well we will the
Cobra was taking place yesterday so
we're looking at the operational
responsibilities from that but they yes
that we are going to be looking at a
series of options but let's also make it
clear that this is international waters
that we're speaking about the critical
geo strategic pinch point in the world
and we are committed to do our role on
the international stage to keep these
waterways open and therefore we need an
international solution so we'll be
working speaking with our colleagues our
international allies to see what can
actually be done you're talking about
how critical these waters are not with
that in mind knowing how volatile the
Iranian regime is why what these ships
protect it well we have a number of
vessels three or four vessels going
through a hundred nautical miles of
waterway a
every single day it's not just us but
the international community is there as
well it is impossible simply to escort
each individual vessel there's been talk
for example of a skiing with the us to
try and guard vessels through the Strait
of I mean why why yes and that's
actually what's happening but let's
place into context this has been a
sudden spike in activity in threat
that's ratcheted up in the last few
weeks itself and and absolutely it takes
time to respond there we are sending an
additional type 45 destroyer there
there's also an RFA support ship that's
coming so we can actually replenish at
sea we are absolutely committed to
providing a military presence in the
Middle East and keeping these Straits
open okay well let's just have a look at
what Julian Lewis the chair of the
defence Select Committee has said he
said this it was blindingly obvious that
British flank vessels should not have
been allowed to navigate this waterway
unaccompanied have we taken our football
a bit no not at all and again a huge
respect for determine of the defence
Select Committee but as I say a hundred
nautical miles of waterway number of
ships British flag ships or
international ships that are going
through there we look after British flag
ships all over the world we have our
shipping interests right across the
globe when a threat spiked such as this
yes we move more assets into the area
but we can't simply as the tanker wars
in 1980s showed we simply cannot escort
each individual ship that is not a
long-term solution to this we need to
recognize that there is a threat we do
need to provide solutions that allow
shipping to continue but ultimately we
need to focus on what is causing this
the geopolitical stress that Iran is
actually engaging with only until that
is solved well we actually see some form
of a kind of stability in that area it
kind of helped can it that the foreign
secretary is currently taking part in a
leadership contest I'm not so we can't
deny that that is our democratic process
I won't shy away from the fact that the
threat is increased now and we are
responding to it we are sending assets
to the region but ultimately Iran taking
about let me just let me just finish
this point because it is an important
one to make if we want to continue
playing a role on the Internet
stage bearing in mind that threats are
changing all happening believe just
beneath the threshold of all-out war
then we must invest more in our defence
including our Royal Navy our Royal Navy
is too small to manage that our interest
across the globe if that's our future
intentions and that's something the next
Prime Minister will need to to recognize
now you served in Iran when you're in
the army visited Iran as Middle East
Minister how dangerous are they
I didn't just clarify I didn't serve in
Iran was there but I did visit as
foreign minister and very interesting to
see the people of Iran are desperate for
a better relationship with the
international community so our argument
is with the regime itself on what
they're doing not just in this
particular area of swatting
international business in the shipping
lanes but also its proxy negative
influence in Syria in the civil war in
Yemen in Iraq in Bahrain in Lebanon as
well
these are unhelpful interventions these
aren't the acts of a nation that really
should be trying to join the
international community for the benefit
of all what they are doing here is they
are on the receiving end of changes in
sanctions from the United States and
they're lashing back out and probably to
affect the oil price are you worried
that the u.s. and Iran could be heading
for a military complex I think everybody
is worried about that which is why the
foreign secretary the defense secretary
as well is wanting to make sure that we
de-escalate we have seen as I say a
ratcheting up the last three weeks of
events and tensions in the Straits of
Hormuz and with Iran as a whole we need
to make sure that we thought this go
back to the bigger picture of the
relationship with Iran and make sure
that we protect our international
shipping I just want to show you a tweet
that term in Corbin sent yesterday and
the leader Labor Party said this the UK
tanker under Iranian control and its
crew must be released escalation risks a
deeper conflict all sides must show
restraint Trump tearing up the Iran
nuclear deal has fuelled confrontation
it's negotiated reinstatement is
essential to defuse a threat of war in
the Gulf is he right that Donald Trump
has fueled the confrontation well
firstly can I pleased to see that the
finally the opposition leader is
actually supporting our armed forces in
some way they actually
remove us from NATO they reduce our
Armed Forces capability and remove the
nuclear detects and the past is now
coming in support and recognizing this
important thing but there is a concern
that we have a difference of opinion
with the United States on the nuclear
deal itself France Germany and ourselves
believe that this has played paid
dividends it's actually prevented
nuclear weapons being developed in Iran
unfortunately they're now going back to
their uranium enrichment program because
of what the Americans have done and we
can't deny that this operational this
tactical threat and escalation of issues
in the Straits of Hormuz if factors into
this bigger picture and we've been
dragged into an issue that is really
between the u.s. and Iran I don't think
can be dragged into this is the
international community which must stand
firm on supporting international norms
and that's exactly why this is being
treated as a hostile act
and probably in response to grace one
which is the Iranian ship that was
seized off to broader that was because
it was breaching international and EU
sanctions in wanting to supply oil to
Syria now with Iran can't have it both
ways
they can't pretend to want to join the
international community but then flout
just international sanctions but then
get angry with us when we actually seize
a ship because of that okay now while
I've got you and we may have a new well
we will have a new prime minister in two
days time which looks likely to be Boris
Johnson bearing in mind that you think
No Deal would be a bad thing for the UK
could you say them as cabinet well I
really got frustrated with this energy
towards no deal I know all my
parliamentary colleagues on all sides of
the house recognize the dangers of No
Deal a fact that we keep talking about
it it isn't a solution I'm very
concerned and I really encourage would
you serve in Boris Johnson government no
I'm gonna make it very very clear I want
us to move away from discussion about no
deals all I believe in a a deal is
absolutely possible the fact that we
keep talking about No Deal fuels the
caucus small caucus of people that see
that as an as their destination No Deal
is not a destination you run away from
the EU and say fine we don't want to
have a deal you'll still have to crawl
literally moments later to say what how
is our financial services gonna operate
how is our operations with peace gonna
work how citizens rights going to work
how are they going to respond when we've
just run the other way and then come
crawling back to the table sick No Deal
is a distraction from where I want the
Prime Minister to focus which is getting
a deal and we can achieve that so if you
think all that about No Deal could you
serve what are yours you're almost
making my point for me
all these if you or whatever is I don't
even want to go down that direction I
won't want you might have to make a
decision about it I'll make a decision
about that when that actually comes what
I am so worried about is that we now
know more about no deal than we do about
seeking other solutions for deal this
cliche that we've just we know we're
able to land a man on the moon 50 years
ago but we can't sort out the Northern
Line and backstop we can there is a will
in Parliament if we don't do that then
Parliament will the Conservative Party
could be destined to be an opposition
for an awful long time and that's the
danger that I hope every one of my
colleagues will wake up to and of course
the Prime Minister the next prime
minister to